so this is the topic i will explain what
this trattoria some point okay so let's
start with the general question of
bounds and binary codes so an error
correcting code of length and distance D
is a subset of the discrete cube such as
for in two distinct points the distance
between them is at least the Hamming
distance so it's basically a packing of
you know the joint hemming balls of
radius D minus 1 over 2 and want to know
how well we can pack what's the largest
Congeniality of such packing and the
range of distances d we're interested in
is linear in n so fix a parameter Delta
and deed is Delta a delta between zero
and one half in this range it's easy to
see that the packing would be
exponential in n depending on this
parameter Delta and what we don't know
is what this exponent is it's a big open
question corresponding to this big open
question Euclidean geometry is the
optimal density of packing you know
you're creating balls it's very similar
in the techniques are essentially the
same for bound right so this is a big
open question we won't solve it in this
talk okay so but let's talk a bit about
bounds so these are the simple you know
classical bounds on the sides of the
packing so the upper bound is just say
volume argument right so we want to pack
this jointly both of radius D minus 1
over 2 b's a hammock ball this is radius
so the is the best possible packing is
it most the size of the space jose space
divided by the size of the of the object
you want to pick and the lower bound you
can get by a simple greedy argument a
greedy argument so you take a point put
it into your packing this is the center
of one of the balls you throw away the
ball around this point you still have
some space left you take another point
throw away the ball around this point
and this is a little bit so taking logs
out of this we get this a bound these
bounds on the exponent this is between 1
minus a bar
binary entropy of Delta and 1 minus a by
binary entropy of dirt over to where
this is the definition of an entropy
which everybody knows of course and we
use effects as the cardinality of the
Hamming bowl is to to the entropy of its
radius over n times them up to
negligible factors right so this has the
simple bounds and the best-known bound
at least 4 z4 for about half of the
distances a delta is this bound due to a
Mac Elise Radha Mitchell arms in welch
from 77 following the linear programming
approach of there's art so this is
abound and notice that something strange
is going on because we have the
cardinality of a pecking bounded from
above very coordinated Cobra hemming
ball right in the exponent which is kind
of weird we bound this sort of you know
the size of epsilon at a dispersed
object right by this very dense object
and some duality is some duality is
involved somehow and you know we'll get
to it right so we have this and it's up
this bound is the best known it's not
optimal the best known for deltas
between zero point two seven three and
one-half wait so in this talk we only
speak about only discuss linear code
this is a special class of codes so it's
a pecking whose centers are a linear
subspace of the cube and it has many
similarities to let a specking scenario
instead of regular packings this is
obviously a more structured setting but
unfortunately the bounds we know exactly
the same we don't have any better bones
for those and you know so what can you
do they want to improve the pounds and
you know we don't know how to approach
the bouts at least one to understand the
bounds better so you know so let me tell
you briefly how do you prove in a
program pounds so this is how we program
program balance you taken tutorial
problem you embed it into algebraic
setting up association of cessation
schemes you get some linear inequalities
use linear program attracts a shin
user fidelity you get to extremal
problem and university polynomials use
orthogonal polynomials to solve it and
you get of course you know you shouldn't
be able to understand this so it's
complicated right this is a this is the
way you prob'ly in your program so but
we do have a much nicer proof of this
bound due to fremont ilic from 2002 for
linear codes so let me tell you about
this so we have a code a packing you
know in the in the end dimensional cube
with minimal distance d so what we
consider we consider this quotient space
t which is f 2 to the M divided by Z by
Z dual code so C perp is a orthogonal
subspace and we want somehow at least
intuitively to think about this is the
descriptors we are talking about
similarly to if we divide you know RN by
lattice we get to continuous terms hey
linear algebra tells us that the size of
T is exactly the size of C so you want
to upper bounds empty and ok questions
okay so we think about these stores as a
metric space as a Kayla graph well if i
should say it's a quotient group we have
this we have addition and taking the
unit vectors to be a giant except we get
a cary-grove we can assume without
losing anything that all of these are
distinct so we get an end regular graph
with this adjacency relation and you
know it's a nice it's a que de Graaff
it's a nice vertex transition graph and
we want to know how large it is so we
want some you know tools to to be able
to to understand how how large is graph
is so here's a copy is a couple of
examples just to you know to to get a
feeling on a what can you expect from
what kind of graphs do you get so let's
take C to B z'ha'dum our code so here n
is 2 to the K minus 1 and this is a
generating matrix of C and I'm writing
here all the vectors of length scale of
the nonzero vectors of length scale
right so this is K and this is M
so right so what would be so I'm looking
at the T as a store of T which is f 2 to
the n / seeker so what's the graph is
the question from Saudi busy busy having
killed by their token on subspace it's
not a tricky question yeah so it's in n
regular graph on 2 to the K points which
is n plus 1 so it's a click great so
this is easy what about some of to harm
our codes on this joint subspaces so you
get a graph product going to show you
some things it gets on some drops if Z
right it can if you have repeated
coordinates but it's sort of not very
interesting grid I guess great so we
want to know how large this graph is and
we want to grow to caesars you want to
grow neighborhoods around some point
it's a vertex transitive graph around 0
right so sr is a sphere of radius R
around 0 this is basically the set what
it corresponds to the set of cassettes
of superb with cassette leaders which
are vectors of minimal weight exactly
are you think about this right so I
looking at shifts of the dual code of
the orthogonal subspace such as the
minimal weight or vector in this in this
you know a fine subspace is exactly and
what to know we want to understand how
fast these Union the metric balls around
zeros Union to the spheres grow right so
we want to know how many cassettes how
many points we have on each sphere and
this is exactly this is known in coding
theory as understating weight
distribution of cost leaders how many
points of each wait do we have in this
in the stores and unfortunately this is
a notoriously difficult question in
coding theory understanding the weight
distribution of
leaders even for some simple subspace
some simple codes it's very difficult
right so friend until each avoid this
problem dealing with this problem
directly and they deal with the touristy
only by using comparison theorem so
tubes in tuition somehow comes from
Romania in geometry comparing to the one
sort of constant curvature if Iran space
the bouillon cube 012 thing so i'll give
you the proof so we have the size of the
ball of radius R around zero in the
Taurus is at most this endemic which it
as a projection right this is simple and
we also have a more surprising
inequality so I'll explain what it means
so the laplacian I ghen value of the
jury I can value of this ball in the
Taurus is at most this in the cube so
what does it mean so a laplacian I ghen
value of a subset is the minimal
Rayleigh ratio for in observation which
is used or graphic lesson for functions
supported in this subject okay so I'm
taking function support only the subset
and I am looking at you know a gr8
Rayleigh ratio so f is supported in
omega I'm looking at this divided by
this and I want menu right for all
nonzero f's supportive mimic so notice
that the larger the set is the smaller
its laplacian eigenvalues so if i take
everything at x it can take the constant
function and i get 0 right if I so this
inequality somehow surprising the
combination of these two because you
know the ball in the Taurus is smaller
than the ball in the in the cube but
it's a prescient eigen value is smaller
so how this could be true question to
the audience now now there are two
different lessons in two different
spaces rate one of them is a tourist and
one of them in the insecure and
the Buddha British are in the totals
corresponds to to a union of both only
to you yes so and then I would have an
equality in the in the in the laplacian
I get okay so and this corresponds
somehow was intuition of Raymond tillage
came from this theorem comparison
theorem of junk in your manager ama tree
which basically states the same it's not
how to put right and now we are almost
done so and the last thing seemed to
observe is that the laplacian I ghen
values in the stores so the first
eigenvalue zero but the second is 2d
twice d because we know what the
eigenvectors are the eigenvectors as the
characters of the cube supported in the
space see and because the minimum
distance pace c is d the mineral
eigenvalue is large it's it's a very
simple thing to see so since the second
of the same eigenvalue is 2d if you have
a set whose laplacian I ghen value is
smaller tuned to ascend to the smaller
by some you know fixed amounts i say it
most to d minus one then michael
schwartz we get this should be almost
the whole space so we are done so choose
a radius R question we spoke basically
was proving zagging well the bomb yeah
yes that problem so I'm telling ya thank
you good so choose choose choose a
radius R so that's a plus C an
eigenvalue of the hemming ball in the
cube is it most a smaller than 2 d minus
1 this we can do because this is an easy
computation which they do but this was
also done before basically this is a you
know to bounce this laplacian i can
value it's exactly to compute the
location of the first zero in the
appropriate is on all spiracle function
the appropriate of jerk polynomial this
is this is what to what you do this is
basically solving quadratic equation
then we know that the first reply see an
eigen value of the corresponding bones
taurus is it most is it most that in the
cube is smaller than 2d and therefore
the size of the code
is basically the size the size the size
of the code is the size of the toros by
linear algebra this is by these
laplacian Tigan values is almost the
same as the size of this hammock of this
bowl in the Toros and this is small or
equal than the side of the bottle
internship and we are done right this is
a proof right very nice questions he
because you know so look at Z so you're
talking about this rate I can't use this
month it went somewhere third point so
because if you look at the eunuch
artistic function of Omega and just
write it out as a combination of
characters right of the eigen functions
so where do you get the contribution how
do you get such a small I can value
because have to have large inner product
with all one function as I mean your
large this gives the first finger
program bound which is a yeah I don't
know and this is also only falling
archos right this is only fully on a
phone interview it can okay so a right
so let me you know have 11 slide which I
didn't have originally as an aside on
other proofs and extensions this follows
the question of guilt in the first
lecture in this a workshop so if you
look at this proof is that this you know
should have some free analytic you know
interpretation because you know the
eigenfunctions of the Toros characters
and so on and one should be able to do
something so to be more precise this is
not exactly the proof we so because this
is not exactly the proof present in
freedom and tillage that one is
reservoir this is kind of a streamlined
version of the true so but one can come
up with a fully analytic proof which
sort of doesn't have to look at the
Torah it works only with the cube itself
and the report has all kinds of
extensions so for instance we
immediately get the same not only for
for you know linear codes but also so we
basically have proved
that the code is small equivalently the
dual code the program code is large and
your total code is a device independent
set because the distance in the in the
code was D but one immediately gets more
that you know the device independent
sites which do not come Miss Sarah
miracles also large and also by you know
some analysis one extends to general
binary code not only near codes because
he don't have we don't need this
quotient objects rate and also by so
that one was with Michael Devon and the
other thing is a other extension of his
Naga it was no editing so you can prove
similar bounds for designs in many
symmetric spaces which are graphs and
romanian manifolds with many cemeteries
and so design is a finite set of points
on which all the simple eigenfunctions
of the laplacian corresponding too small
eigenvalues vanish in average so Sam
them over this point since they vanish
so you have can have spherical designs
on the sphere or device independent sets
and so on so the proof goes like that so
it have this design in your symmetric
space and you start to grow
neighborhoods around points of the
design and for sufficiently large radius
you cover almost everything and
therefore you know and you know you have
a bound of the straightest so therefore
your set of point is large and this is
this gives a uniform proof of the bounds
on designs we sure proved you know in in
several papers you know like starting
from the 70s still 2009 or something in
projective spaces in spherical you know
on the sphere and so and so and in
various groves okay so infosphere as
well make it about it sounds potential
bomb yeah but we still don't know equals
exponent is the upper bounds before that
we're double X conventional way two to
the N squared or something now they have
a simple exponential but exponent is
your honor okay so so so look at this so
now how is it related to the question of
Hamid and Gil
as a premature if you start from a
device independent set so suppose this
is a cube right you start from a device
independent set you start to grow
neighborhoods it turns out that the
growth is faster the growth is faster
than what you get from you know from
looking at you know hyper conductivity
say applying noise because when if you
just look at estimate you get from hyper
conductivity you get worse bounce worse
than linear programming so you do have
some advantage if you look at you as
independent sets but and if you can
improve this advantage you'll get better
bounds for foliar for at least put in
your code should be very somehow it
tells us that there is something
slightly better but it would be hard to
improve because then I also or at least
improve significantly somehow right ok
so right so what but now going back to
this proof of pregnant ilic what can we
learn from this proof so it's good to be
able to control growth of neighborhoods
of balls in the Torah and if it can so
this is big thing about this proof if we
can show that actually these equalities
holders inequality either the metric
balls and the terms grow slower all the
eigenvalues are smaller convincin in
your program bound so this sort of gives
you an only way to try and improve
linear program bounds so we have thought
about this for quite a while and you
know we can do it we don't know how to
do it but we can do some simple things
so let me give you an example one can
improve the best known bounds for LDPC
codes these are low-density parity-check
codes which means that they're doing
codes they do all sub spaces are spend
by constant weight vectors suppose what
waits three batteries great so the claim
yeah so we can ask ourselves how large
this code could be given so we now have
a linear packing of having balls in you
know in in the discrete cube with an
additional structure so the structure is
at the dual space spanned by lower
weight watchers and we have bound so
there are bounds by Borstein crevel
average listen
2002 and been hiding village in 2006
improving bring your program bones
because we have additional stretch and
what we are going to prove that in fact
in this case we can show that the magic
balls in the Toros growth potential
slower than those in the whole space and
therefore we're getting a bit wait so
this would improve the balance for you
know for almost all distances and there
is a proof here but let me give you a
very simple proof at least for the case
of three souls a dual subspace is spent
by by vectors of length 3 so let me show
how how we can improve it so this is the
Toros this is zero and now i'm looking
at two spheres of radius R and radius R
plus one so i want to a look at this
picture compared to the corresponding
picture for the fours a hammock you for
this is 0-1 to them so how fast do the
neighborhood grow in the hammock you
will know exactly for any point here for
any point is here we have so how many
points we have going outside going
further away from zero right so this is
the point so this is the point of it are
this exactly the points a distance 10
wait r plus 1 so we have n minus R
points right we have n minus our points
going out and we have our points going
down this is the geometry of the cube so
I'm going to try and convince you that
here for any point X we have only n
minus at most n minus 2 our points going
further away from 0 this will tell us
immediately that these vulgar expansion
slow and why is it so look at a point X
a weight are so look take a a coset
leader a representative in this cassette
or weight are so so each point of this
through each point of the set of suppose
the support of X we have a linear
dependency of length 3 passing through
it and it passes only through one point
to it otherwise we'll get a shorter
representative
they feel good for a second so now I
claim that if I go in any of these
directions I don't go up very trivial
linear algebra and so I won't do it it's
very very easy and the union of all
these you know our sets each of them is
of size 3 is of cardinality again very
simply at least two are so all these
directions i do not go up so i should
either stay on the sphere or go down and
this is it right to it's very simple ok
tell this is use a very simple example
okay so yeah this is a proof which I
don't want to show okay so this was a
very simple application now we can
forget a about junior program bounds and
just ask ourselves how can we control
you know you have this a you have this
graph how can we control the growth of
metric balls on this graph right so how
so we are we are going to try to use
this intuition Freeman tillage that
Romanian is this point of your Romanian
geometry is nice so what so in Romanian
German to see do have tools to control
growth of to prove upper bounds on
growth of neighborhoods of the of a
point by using curvature so we have this
notion of richie curvature in romanian
geometry and this notion allows to
compare is the rate of a gross of
neighborhood of a point and rate at the
end of I ghen values of these
neighborhoods between a constant
curvature space and between spaces which
do not necessarily have constant
curvature but have at least the
curvature of the Constitution space so
and the sort of is a lesson to take from
it we have high curvature is a metric
bulbs grow slowly so we want to find a
notion of curvature and graphs that will
allow us to do this right so we are
thinking about the descriptors is it
discreet manifold Nadine want a notion
of discrete curvature so one can look
for such a notion in the literature and
there are several notions you there is
one you told yes there is
want you to villainy and probably some
others and we're going to the one due to
olivia is easier this is the one we are
going to use so now I'm let me you know
tell you in so we have changed the topic
right we spoke about linear programming
bounds and we are done with that we
slightly improved linear program bounds
for some simple codes and now we want to
forget about all this and we speak about
general graphs and bounds on growth you
know of neighborhoods of points in these
graphs and we all wanted to use this
note a notion of courage so the
intuition so I'm going to define this
it's a very simple definition and it
tries to capture the following a
tradition that in in a flat space when
flat metric space and the curvature is
zero it's sort of says that I can shift
points in parallel so if I have two
small balls around two points I can
shift I have a parallel shift and the
distance between the both would be
exactly the distance between the Centers
so ever it is and if they have you know-
curvatures and sort of balls grow
further apart somehow like that and in a
positive curvature to grow together and
therefore some of the growth is slower
this is the intuition I want to try and
capture so okay so now we have an end
regular graph and for a vertex of this
graph consider a uniform probability
measure on this vertex on n its
neighbors so we have a point X it has a
neighbors and we define wait 1 over n
plus 1 on any point including the
sentence ok so and now i want so i know
i have the notion of distance this is
just is usually signified by the graph
now i want to define the notion of
distance between two distributions on
these balls which was a try and capture
the notion of average distance between
these balls and it is very simple so i'm
looking at all the possible ways to
match points in this ball around x two
poems in the ball around why and i'm
looking at this expectation of the song
now I'm moving
you know points in one Bowl to the
points in another Bowl and I'm looking
at the average work I'm doing there is
distance okay it was clear it's not so
let me just say that usually we are
considering so this is what certain
distance the distance between
distributions we are doing the same but
according to any distribution on a
product space whose marginals our m1 and
m2 but here it's easy to see that do we
need only to consider matchings m is a
message by jection rate right so we have
this rate so and we define this notion
Olivia defines this notion of course
rich curvature between x and y 2
business this is cut pub between x and y
this is a function of took on two points
this is 1 minus the average distance
between the balls defined by the
distance between centers so you know if
it's if the distance between the you
know metric between the neighborhoods of
x and y is greater is every distances
greater the distance between the
center's this is negative curvature if
it's the same at 0 as a Reuters positive
ok so a and for a graph we set the
curvature of the graph to be the minimal
curvature region points any penny pairs
of points is ok ok so let's see some
examples so I claims that the Kayla
graph of an abelian group is not
negatively curved and this is trivial
because i have a parable ship straight
this is very easy a regular tree is
negatively curved actually an is this so
sort of gives additional meaning to this
notion that really is a hyperbolic a
space and we can ask
problem they're gone great hey this is
everything sort of every that's the
first approximation so and so what about
the hanging cube so it's a very simple
observation that the curvature any graph
is attained it Jason points suggest a
consequence so the triangle inequality
because if someone wanted general
complaint from their progress is it this
is completely standard notion of
contractive coupling for simple random
walk it existed long before again he
says something about just actually a
different name but there is nothing new
in the concept it exactly coupling of
one step of a simple random walk you
have that contract you can contract with
this there is it so and this fact you
just mentioned yours is known in
computer science and the path coupling
exactly so it's just it he did it much
later so you know I'm very happy to hear
so there is much known about this
probably more than Olivia right okay you
would another therapist I think I'll
continue right so this notion right
sorry so what about what about a
curvature in the queue right what about
the hem cube so the curvature is
attempted points of this is one and you
know in the cube the neighborhoods of
any two points intersect in you know in
two spaces into neighborhoods of any two
adjacent points x and y intersect
exactly in X and in Y can draw it for
some reason you probably believe me this
is X this is y these are neighbors right
both x and y are interval so great so
this tells us that our matching doesn't
have to move two points x and y stay in
place right and we define matching very
easily so such as protection distance we
only move n minus 1 points distance one
and therefore you know it's n minus 1
divided by n plus
one and the curvature you know is it
least 2 over n plus 1 but we can show
it's exactly it's very easy to see it so
it is so what about touring so obviously
the same argument also holds for
tourists and the character is this but
maybe in some cases we can have more so
can we do better and curvature is a
local notion so I want local constraints
if you have local constraints in our
codes you'll get you know better bounds
on the gorgeous sure it just by trying
to encourage it's just like thank you
yes well let's see okay so it depends
not on to a substrate so so we want
local constraints so let C be a code
with a local constraint of length 3
meaning that superb the foie gras
subspace contains a vector of extreme
what can you say right so I want to get
a non-trivial bound on curvature so
suppose this constraint contains
coordinate I so then I claim that the
neighborhoods of X if Y is X plus e I a
go interaction I the intersection for
points so if this if the constraint
contains the points I J&K then I claim
they also intersect in X plus y j + X +
ck this is very simple its immediate and
in general if you have T vectors passing
through ice coordinate of length 3 then
Z you know the curvature in this
direction is at least is at least the
neighborhood intersect a lot so these
balls are glued together in many points
and therefore the curvature is at least
2 t + 1 / MS 1 right so everything is
going to be very very simple right so
great so we have this sort of understand
sighs so what now we are looking for
examples of
luckily constraint codes and we have in
computer science many such families we
have locally decodable codes local
testable codes locally correctable codes
it will talk about local electrical
codes already heard you know talk about
shivangi yesterday about this about the
notion of Oklahoma codes right so a
linear code is locally correctable these
two queries if for any coordinate it has
many vectors of length three containers
coordinate so here's the theorem of
pencil song and elements of soon we
shall determine from 2009 assumes that
we have many vectors of length 3 passing
through any coordinate so you know of
our code and as soon as there are no
repeated coordinates in our code so the
dual code contains no vectors of lengths
to then we have this bound is a
cardinality of a the cardinality of the
code is it most this up to a logarithmic
factor right sorry have to taking looks
on both sides so for right so I guess
that if T is this number if tau in his
number tau is a constant so we have
linear linear many vectors this was
already known but I think that for some
a range of values of tau a this was not
known for tau this is explained in the
paper of Michelle and Ellie so the proof
goes like that so you're used to la
critical double codes which is the
weekend ocean and you use some variation
you prove a new variation of the edges
of aromatic lemma which is kind of daily
requires certain motor work so let's
just try and prove it using this
curvature thing so what do we know about
graphs is high with high curvature so
intuitively they should be small because
metric balls grow slowly in fact they
actually stopped growing at some point
and this is what is you know what is
stated by simone myers theorem in
romanian geometry so if you have a
manifold whose curvature is bounded from
below budget of a sphere of a constant
curvature a manifold then its diameter
is at most set of the sphere and we have
z Olivia or you know or maybe some other
people a we have this discrete version
of this
suppose they have a graph of courage any
metric space in a discrete metric space
a of curvature kappa then the diameter
of this graph is at most to overcome so
let me prove it this is a very easy
statement so right so suppose we have
two points a distance D in our space and
I want to bound this distance so this
distance is capital D and I want an
upper bound of torque up on this
distance so I'm going to bounce this
distance from above sorry I'm going to
bound the amount of work which will take
me to move you know the uniform
distribution on zinc on the neighborhood
of X to the uniform distribution of the
neighborhood on why I want to build it
from two sides so on one hand they claim
this is upper bounded by 1 minus Kappa
times D because you know kappa is so
this is by triangle inequality so to
move one in this direction takes me one
minus couple this is amount of work by
definition and in other words drag and
produces on the other hand I want to
bound it from below so this is at least
by the triangle inequality is a distance
between this measure muaks and the Delta
measure etics sorry a sorry I don't want
this I want the distance between two
Delta measures and Delta X and Delta Y
minus the distance between delta x + MX
minus the distance between Delta Y and
my yes ok now the distance between Delta
measures is d this is trivial this is D
and the distance between two
distribution measures to probability
measures so to support your distance one
is at most one so this is it this is at
least d minus two so we get that one
minus Kappa times D is at least d minus
two and we are done right varies so the
diameter is it most a 2 over top wait a
good so how are we going to use it so
here is a proof so now so recall this
this claim of benzoin bidermann we have
that so any cordon a pass that
manufacturers of length 3 consider the
Taurus the curvature is at least 2 T
plus 1 divided by M plus 1 as we have
noticed therefore the diameter of the
turtles is it most n plus 1 divided 2 /
kappa which is therefore the cardinality
of the code is that of the turtles which
is z2 most the cardinality of the ball
of radius n plus 1 divided by T plus 1
in the turtles which is at most the
cardinality of the currently
corresponding Bowl in same in cube and
we are done right so this is the proof
okay very simple and so since get more
complicated when we have multiplicities
for some reason okay right so an
additional effect is so we prove that
say small because the Toros has small
diameter which is equivalent to the fact
that the orthogonal code has a small
cover introduced so you can get near
every point in the hemming cube by a
point in the insert in ze or token code
right therefore it's very large
therefore the original code is very
small right so this is the proof and you
know the somehow the trouble in these
locally constraint codes happens when
you allow repeated coordinates and
things become much more complicated and
elionwy hell proved if you allow
repetition coordinates but each
coordinate repeats equal number of times
they prove this bound with more work but
in our case you know the same argument
gives actually a tight bound which is
slightly better so now if we have K
occurrence classes of coordinates then
we are looking actually at a graphic a
regular graph but the spiral edges so
there mm edges but you're only care of
them a different and we consider the
induced measure on neighborhood of
points given by this so it's not a
uniform measure anymore but
okay one computes distance and one gets
about so everything is very simple ah
and well you know so I am actually you
know rang out of slides not out of time
sorry yeah well I'd still have like
three minutes late so we can do the same
with a result of original and tally
kaufman on locally testable codes with
large distance again it takes a
non-trivial amount of work to prove
bounds and with this notion of curvature
it's basically immediate and I guess we
can do the slightly more let me just say
that since i have another minute that
what happens with the heart they you
know they really sort of interesting
questions when there are more than two
queries right this is hard and there we
have a very simple argument which gives
a bound using this curvature notion
which is bit which is better than what a
you know chasm Travis and got using the
information theoretic approach but worse
than what Canada Centre wolf go to using
quantum information direct approach so
it's in between somehow for some real
reasons and and right
so this approach seems to be working
with local local constraints because the
notion of curvature is based on very
small name shirt Oh is there something
so we were hoping great space with
requests right so this notion of a
certain distance is like using somehow
this amount of work you move like so and
the question is can this be done in a
smarter way great and hopefully yes but
we don't know rose from there to there
right moving mass around but
but thankfully nice